- Today we're gonna be talking about
what you need to know
about law school exams
so you can crush your next final.
So stick around and get
an edge in law school.
(cheery music)
Where to begin about law school exams?
The first thing you should
know is that almost all
law school exams consist
of issue spotting essays.
Sometimes called hypotheticals
or hypos for short.
Sometimes you'll see multiple choice
or term papers in classes,
but in your first year of law school
they are almost always issue spotters.
The first thing you'll notice
about an issue spotting exam
is that it starts with a big story.
A big story where bad things happen.
If it were a criminal law exam,
your average issue
spotting exam would consist
of people running around
murdering, conspiring,
assaulting, and worse.
If it was a property
exam, you'd probably have
some sort of land dispute
between different parties
or restrictions on land.
If it was a contract exam,
you'd have a contract
where some people would
claim it was a contract
and some people would claim
it was an invalid contract.
There will be lots of people
doing lots of things to each other.
That came out wrong.
At any rate, at the end of the
story there will be a prompt.
The prompt usually consists
of something very vague
like explain the rights
of the various parties
or what claims does Mrs.
Smith have against Mr. Jones?
The reason it's called
an issue spotting exam
is that you're going to have
to cull through those facts
to come up with the issues
that need to be discussed.
Here is the main thing that
you need to understand.
An issue spotter is not
about regurgitating the law
or just regurgitating the facts.
In a college essay exam
you get lots of points
simply for writing down
things that you memorized.
So if you were taking a
class on American history
and the essay asked about
the American Revolution,
you'd probably get lots of
points for talking about
when the important battles were fought,
the causes of the revolution,
the name of the British taxes,
the names of the founding
fathers and etc, etc.
Facts and figures don't get
you any points in law school.
Generally you're analyzing the facts
as a litigator would and
it's all about application.
You're looking for
claims and counter claims
and defenses and counter defenses
that one party can bring against the other
or that they can use to protect
against the claims of another party.
An issue spotting exam is
all about the application.
You have to learn the law
and then apply the facts
that are given to you in the issue spotter
to the law that you know.
In this way it's kind of like
a mechanical engineering exam.
You can imagine that if
an engineering professor
spent a semester
explaining how a car works,
it would be fair game at the end
to ask the students to design
a car for the final exam.
It applies what they have learned.
Law school exams are sort of the same way.
You are applying the law
to a given set of facts.
Memorizing the law is of course necessary,
but those are the table
stakes in law school.
Knowing the law will get
you through the door,
but knowing the law alone
won't even get you a C,
let alone a B or an A on the test.
Learning how to apply the law is a skill.
It takes practice, but it's
a skill that can be learned.
What I hate is that so
many professors claim
that essay writing is an art
that is incapable of being learned.
In fact, although they
would not admit it to you,
the professor has an
interest in making you think
that it is some dark art
that can't be learned.
Your professor wants you to
believe that some people have it
and some people don't.
But this is just nonsense.
No one is born with the
skills of being able
to write a law school exam, that's crazy.
It's just a skill and just
like learning to ride a bike
or making a free throw or learning guitar,
you can learn the skills
that are important
for a law school essay exam.
Believe me, if you can
learn to pass the LSATs,
then you can learn to answer
an issue spotting exam.
During your first year,
they almost all tend to
be issue spotting exams.
But the good news is
that you can learn how
to beat those tests.
It's a skill, it just takes practice.
Over time you'll get better at them.
Don't worry if you don't
start out writing A worthy
issue spotting exam essays.
No one starts out that way.
It just takes practice.
With practice you'll get better.
If you take practice
exams you can get an edge
on everyone else in your class.
Oh and by the way, if you
wanna get better grades
on your next law school
final check this out.
We've put together a free ebook called
The Ultimate Guide to
Crushing Law School Finals.
Just click the link below to download it.
It'll show you exactly how to
prepare for your next final
including how to plan, how to outline,
and how to study for your next final.
Just click below.
Also if you liked this video,
please subscribe to our channel.
We come out with new videos on how crush
law school all the time.
So thanks from everyone
here at Legal Eagle.
(techno music)